what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
happy new year to everyone i hope
everybody is being safe out there
tonight i know it's already new years
for some people and happy new years to
you and i know some people are only a
few hours away and i just want to say
thank you so much for making 2021 an
awesome year for me and the marvel
community this year has been a very
interesting year because we were still
kind of in the pandemic but we did get a
lot of awesome marvel movies and shows
we got one division the falcon and the
winter soldier the loki series marvel's
what if we got hawkeye black widow
shangchi the eternals and spider-man no
way home and just as i thought even
though spider-man no way home is already
out in theaters we're still talking
about spider-man because there's more
spider-man stuff coming in the future
and we're going to break it all down and
thank you to buksu for sponsoring this
video more on them in a bit so sony and
marvel studios have already confirmed
that there is indeed going to be another
spider-man trilogy that is taking place
in the mcu with tom holland tom holland
is getting three new films and if you
saw spiderman now at home and you know
how that ended you kind of get an idea
of what's going to be going on with
peter parker and that's awesome news we
all want more from tom holland but we
also want more from andrew garfield and
it's looking like that's exactly what
we're going to get it's been reported by
a few accounts including my time to
shine hello and daniel rpk two accounts
that got a lot right about spider-man no
way home that andrew garfield and toby
mcguire are going to be returning not
for one but multiple different films and
right now there's a lot of talk about
what these films could be and it seems
like people have narrowed it down at
least for andrew garfield to three films
rumors that andrew garfield could finish
his spider-man trilogy with the amazing
spider-man number three are going around
like crazy right now and today we have a
little bit more evidence to support this
rumor so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news regarding
the amazing spider-man 3 and of course
other mcu news as well now it's
important to note that if andrew
garfield does indeed return which it's
looking like he is he's going to be
returning not to the mcu but to this
sony universe but he could cross paths
with the mcu every now and then but this
is most likely just in the sony
spider-man universe with venom morbius
craven the hunter etc and like i said
there are three projects out there that
are being reported that andrew garfield
could possibly show up in one of course
would be a venom vs spider-man film with
tom hardy's venom the other one of
course is the amazing spider-man 3 and
the other is a spider-gwen film and
we're going to talk about all of these
and recently and here's the big news
andrew garfield stunt double seemingly
confirmed that he is indeed returning as
well for the amazing spider-man 3. let
me explain what happened but first thank
you to boksu for sponsoring this video
buksu is a premium japanese subscription
snack box they send you one each month
and it is filled with traditional
japanese snacks this is actually the
third one that i've gotten it has to be
my favorite one so far and every month
there's a brand new theme based off of a
season location or holiday in japan and
the snacks come from all over japan from
kumamoto to aomori and they all taste
pretty incredible but this time i have
to say my favorites were the 20th
century pear long dechat the edamame
senbei which i think a lot of people
will enjoy and the mochin dango mochi
which is very sweet and very tasteful a
lot of people will love this now they're
all labeled in japanese completely they
are traditional snacks from japan but
they give you a booklet that tells you
exactly what everything is and what's in
it so if you want to try these amazing
traditional and premium snacks from
japan click the link in the description
down below and use my code cosmic 10 for
10 off so here's what happened with
andrew garfield stuntman on instagram
somebody congratulated william spencer
the stunt double for andrew garfield on
the supposed announcement that he's
going to be returning for the amazing
spider-man 3 the comment said
congratulations on getting the call to
work on tasm 3 in which william spencer
replied thank you so much now this
obviously seems like a very big
confirmation right here that the amazing
spider-man 3 is happening however there
is a possibility that william spencer
simply got the call to return for a
future project and could be assuming
that it is the amazing spider-man 3. now
he later backtracked saying that he was
kidding because of course he's not
supposed to say that if it is indeed
true so he is trying to cover up for
what he said but it does seem very clear
that he is going to be returning to work
as spider-man andrew garfield's stunt
double in some way shape or form in the
future which does seemingly give us a
confirmation that andrew garfield
spider-man is not done now whether
that's in tasm 3 or in another movie
perhaps venom that remains to be seen
but recently of course in the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home and in the post-credits scene for
venom let there be carnage they did
tease that spider-man and venom would
eventually meet and since they went in
that certain direction with spider-man
no way home and peter seems to be doing
something very different than he has
been before it would make sense that it
would be andrew garfield spider-man to
come in and go against venom not to
mention that same account my time to
shine hello said that sony is interested
in making a spider gwen movie now
obviously gwen died in the amazing
spider-man 2 but the multiverse is now a
thing so perhaps andrew garfield might
get a happy ending after all perhaps
there's a universe where gwen is
spider-gwen but she lost her peter
parker so she could meet up with our
angel garfield who lost his gwen and
they could get together this would be
kind of the perfect ending for both of
them regardless of what happens it does
seem like andrew garfield is set to
return and play the amazing spider-man
at least one more time whether that's
the amazing spider-man 3 a spider gwen
film or a film with venom it looks like
he's returning but let me know what you
would like to see in the comments down
below which one of these or would you
like to see something new for him to
return in drop your thoughts and
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to
spider-man all the spider-man and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter i hope everybody
has a safe and awesome new years tonight
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof